[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to afternoo plot details on mm 19's
Joker leaked to the internet yesterday
website we got this covered has also
just dropped details on the outline of
the story for the upcoming movie the
Batman throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about these leaks as well as
what direction I think the studio will
take with this this is full spoilers
ahead so if you don't want anything
potentially ruined about the upcoming
movie then I highly recommend that you
turn off now while it's leaks like this
should always be taken with a pinch of
salt there is potentially major things
about the movie that could be ruined for
you so if you don't want to know
anything about the film then I highly
suggest that you turn off now if you
still here I just want to give a huge
thank you for click in this video I hope
you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my pup breakdown of the
Batman okay so unlike the majority of
films in the dog Knights history
upcoming movie the Batman will focus
more on the characters detective skills
and follow him as he investigates a
string of mysterious murders in Gotham
City aesthetically it will be extremely
similar to the long Halloween which in
my opinion is one of the best if not the
best of Batman graphic novels ever made
in that the Caped Crusader tries to
track down a mysterious killer and I was
simply this holiday the murders key
members of the mob on specific holidays
such as st. Patrick's Day Father's Day
and of course Halloween we heard many
rumors that there would be up to six
villains appearing in the film ranging
from Catwoman to the Riddler penguin and
more and those who read the long
Halloween will know that murder to
murder Batman encounters a full range of
his rogues gallery when attempting to
track down the murderer it's also in
that graphic novel that Harvey Dent
becomes two-face and it would be awesome
if they decided to drag this into the
final film as well in addition to the
aforementioned when investigating the
murders
Batman is supposedly going to run into
the Mad Hatter and Firefly and this will
present some amazing dynamism to
work that we haven't really seen so far
in the live-action movies unfortunately
though there is no joke at and it
remains to be seen whether the movie
will bring the heavy mob as thick into
it that existed in the long Halloween in
that story that mob pretty much run the
town and it's sort of the rise of the
super blowin that transitions got them
from a gangster's paradise into a haven
for the insane reportedly there's a big
twist in the film with it reveal that
there's a criminal controlling
everything though this won't be the
Clown Prince of Crime sources close to
the film have stated that it is in fact
hush aka Thomas Eliot who'll be pulling
the strings and he is tearing through
the city to get revenge on Bruce Wayne
even modeling himself on the character
in a sick obsession the film is
completely disconnected from the other
DC EU films with apparently no ties to
either Man of Steel Batman V Superman or
Justice League throughout the entire
thing primarily Reeves is penning it as
a film noir that will be unlike anything
we've seen so far involving Batman and
aesthetically it will look a lot like
the long Halloween which is heavily
steeped in silhouette and shadow and
that's everything that's been leaked so
far and honestly it has me pretty hyped
for the movie I definitely think this is
the right direction to go with an actor
like Robert Pattinson and it could prove
to really carve out the new direction
for the Dark Knight that shows facets
that we haven't really seen on the big
screen so far as I said earlier the long
Halloween is probably my favorite Batman
graphic novel or a close second to the
cult and I'm really hyped to see this
gets on basis for a movie there's so
much to pull from it and if you haven't
read it I definitely recommend that you
go and pick it up it's got so much going
on in it such as Batman building his
relationship with Catwoman
the mob being taken down by
supervillains a murder mystery and of
course Harvey Dent's transition into
two-face
it's absolutely stacked and yeah you
just need to read it if you're a fan of
comic books obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the news and if it's
made you more excited me or not comment
below and let me know and if you want to
read my 2000 word review of the long
Halloween then I'll link it in the
description alternatively if you want to
stick around on YouTube and learn more
about your favorite comic with movies
then make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the leaks we have on the up
Angelica movie which would be linked at
the end we go over the entire script so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]